this weekend world famous streamer Kai
snat was charged with multiple counts
after a giveaway went wrong the
massively popular twitch streamer is the
number one English-speaking channel on
the platform with almost 6.5 million
followers if that alone has not
convinced you of Kai's popularity this
will
[Applause]
this all began when Kai announced that
he would be doing a giveaway in Union
Square Park in New York City we gonna be
so deep we're doing ps5s PCS keyboards
Mouse packs how much care do you you
know you know you're gonna have to have
like 20 security ads
on me
[Music]
now when it came time to do the giveaway
Kai and his group were already aware of
the impact their arrival would have on
the city yeah
Welcome to New York bro I'm telling you
it's a lot of you out there right now
everybody who's out there makes y'all
safe appreciate everybody who popped up
for y'all bro it's safe
but find us already look at this point
look at them they standing like a
[__] nudity bro the situation however
got quickly out of hand with police at a
press conference later claiming
thousands of young people eventually
showed up the NYPD responding to a
massive out of control crowd Gathering
right now in Union Square Park you see
it right there this is where a social
media influencer told his followers that
he's giving away PlayStations telling
his audience on his live stream to be
safe but also saying everybody for
themselves there's a war out there
[Applause]
we now know more than 60 people were
arrested during this event and hundreds
of people were treated for minor
injuries the chaos came in many
different forms including reports of
fireworks being set off in people
jumping on cars and other structures Kai
himself was caught on camera asking
people to calm down at the giveaway and
he looked like at one point he was
helping a fan who may have been caught
in the chaos
the Buddha
police reportedly made over 60 arrests
also allegedly throwing tear gas into
the crowd there was recorded video that
I cannot show of a police officer
shoving someone's body into a taxi cab
smashing the back window as well as
plenty of recorded footage of young
people being arrested by the police it
was a very tough situation out here and
I really have to commend the women and
men of this department the level of
restraint that they showed and address
of these young people getting this place
cleared out but you know when it was
time for us to make arrests we made
arrests and I think we were very
professional in how we did this I
reached out to the New York City Police
Department who confirmed to me that Kai
was charged with three different counts
Riot inciting a riot and unlawful
assembly the chaos even prompted the
mayor of New York City Eric Adams to
comment on what happened saying thank
you to the New York City Police
Department for their quick work getting
the situation at Union Square under
control today I want our streets to be
alive and full of joy but they must be
safe that's the most important thing
Kai's content group amp posted an
Instagram story saying we are deeply
disheartened by the outbreak of
disorderly conduct that affected
innocent people and business and do not
condone that behavior we apologize for
those impacted and we are fully
cooperating with local authorities
according to the Associated Press Kai
has a day in court on August 18th
reaction online varied from shock and
anger to people saying that others are
being racist in their own reactions to
the situation on a personal level I
believe this was the first introduction
of Kai snat to the mainstream especially
the older Generations this was evidence
see the way the media talked about
Twitch streaming flippantly this was
also evident my mother texted me going
do you know who Kai sanat is for a lot
of people who now know who Kai sanat is
they wouldn't have known him otherwise
if not for this event as for what's next
it looks like Kai will have his day in
court and we will see what happens then
when there are updates to this story we
will let you know
please